foreign
[Applause]
foreign
defined by mistakes and miscalculations
a war that set drones against tanks and
front lines both on the ground and
online tonight Ukraine's Modern War
[Music]
thank you
good evening welcome to the Imperial War
Museum in London generations of
conflicts are remembered recorded and
retold here with experts comparing what
happened in the first and second world
wars with more recent conflicts in the
Balkans Iraq and Afghanistan in future
the war happening right now in Ukraine
will likely be documented here too but
what lessons are being learned from this
war what if anything defines this
conflict from those of the past and as
the nuclear rhetoric Rises could this be
the start of a new global conflict
tonight we'll discuss how he got here
and what could happen next alongside Sky
news correspondents who have witnessed
the ferocity the fear the heartache of
this war Deborah Haynes has spent more
than 20 weeks in Ukraine at various
stages since the conflict began
we'll also hear tonight from Stuart
Ramsey John Sparks and Diana magnet
military expert Michael Clarke has
analyzed every Twist and Turn of which
there have been many as Russia Advanced
and Ukraine fought back and Carl Warner
is principal curator here at the
Imperial War Museum and a cold war
specialist
Plus in his first interview since
stepping down as prime minister I have
spoken exclusively to Boris Johnson for
a candid take on the war so far and why
he thinks Putin would be crazy to launch
a nuclear strike
I think what would happen is that he
would immediately tender Russia's
resignation from the club of civilized
Nations
that interview coming up in full a
little later we also have a 150 strong
audience here too and our panel are
primed and ready to answer your
questions tonight
[Applause]
but let's begin with a look at how this
war has unfolded it's been eight months
since the first Russian missiles struck
cities across Ukraine in the early hours
of February the 24th it was the first
invasion of a sovereign state in Europe
since the second world war and has
caused death destruction Devastation but
also incredible bravery and resilience
the Sheldon is very close
the wreckage of Russian Vehicles is
littering this street it's full of sweet
here we go it started before Dawn
can you hear that Mark
[Music]
it's the only way out of European and
this would test even the fit and healthy
but those still fleeing are the most
vulnerable the elderly the frail and the
very young there's no water no
electricity they're still hanging on I
don't know how they're doing it but they
are they are going west to safety he
will now Head East to fight there is
going to be one Almighty Crush as people
try to get on
all right it's going on behind you now
whatever fell from the sky made a crater
this big
[Music]
that's Crawford from Sky News claw the
sky and stop bombing don't don't speak
about the bureaucratic steps
it's a professional Ambush the bullets
just don't miss
right
join the next the five of us have made
it out of the car down the embankment
and we just can't believe we're alive
good evening from the Ukrainian Capital
cave
see what's left of the missile here the
words on the side of that zadeti it
means four children the train station
was packed with people trying to find a
way out this is what it's like in every
day now
a mass grave here triggered Global
horror
these boys are out every day protecting
their Village but what's left of it with
their own checkpoint and toy guns
at first we were scared
fights like hell
so through here the
making the molotov cocktails
Vladimir Putin thought that Russian
forces would capture key within days
they failed
instead his forces are bogged down in a
war
that they're unwilling to leave and so
far incapable of winning
[Music]
four it is always the children
always the children displaced
always the children without a say in
what adults are doing to their world
it is always the children well in the
next 90 minutes we're going to examine
four key questions for tonight's event
in partnership with the Imperial War
Museum Institute has Ukraine changed
Modern Warfare yes there are tanks and
troops but also uh drones and apps so
how has this war been different then the
big issue right now will Putin go
nuclear he says he's not bluffing but is
that a step too far even for him and
finally winter is coming but what
happens next are we in for a protracted
conflict or is there any Prospect of
Peace in the coming months but first up
who is winning the war right now it may
seem like Ukraine are on top as it
mounts a counter-offensive but it's been
a conflict with ups and downs on both
fronts of course
let's start them with the invasion and
it's fair to say that most observers did
not expect a full-scale uh incursion
Deborah first of all we were there when
it All Began
um how shocked were you when it actually
happened
I think from the UK and the US
side they were the two countries that
had been saying uh contrary to most
other allies that Putin had the
intention to launch a full-scale
Invasion you'll remember there were all
those troops you know more than a
hundred thousand troops massing at the
border so I think because we've been
having these briefings in my head uh I I
knew that it was coming but in reality
when you're seeing a country like
Ukraine with you know people in the
streets I remember on the 23rd of
February being
um in a main street in Kiev watching
through the window of this beautiful
Boutique coffee shop with young women
having a little catch up around a coffee
table eating cake and drinking coffee
and literally then uh in the in the
early hours of the next morning the news
that the war had begun and it was just
it was so profoundly shocking to see a
country and be there as it goes from
relative peace of course it had been in
a state of War since 2014 but from
relative peace to all-out war and all
the Carnage that unfollowed we were in
kharkiv and we were actually filming in
the theater three or four days before
the uh Invasion Michael were you
surprised by Putin's miscalculation
which it clearly was I mean it began
catastrophically was it complacency uh
military naivety or shearing competence
or all three it was interesting
beforehand when we thought something was
bound to happen because it wasn't just
massing troops they were bringing
medical units to the front and blood to
the medical units that told us about a
week before that that you don't take
blood to an exercise unless you expect
to do some fighting so I knew something
was going to happen and I think most of
us thought if he's really Reckless he
might just try and push this land bridge
between the donbass towards Crimea that
would be a very Reckless thing to do but
he might just be mad enough to do that
in the event he went for broke trying to
take the whole country in three days and
that was the idea to replace the the
government in in Kiev to get the whole
operation finished by the 8th of March
and simply take the country over and it
was truly astonishing and the reality
was if it didn't succeed quickly it
wouldn't succeed that's the point if if
the plan a didn't work plan b c and d
will not work either
so Putin is not a loser but he won't
lose gracefully and that's where we are
it's an impossible job that he has given
himself and yes it was it was a huge
surprise I mean some of us never thought
that we would live long enough to see
Europe plunged into this sort of
aggressive war in Invasion an aggressive
war of Conquest you know in the
foreseeable future we thought it might
happen eventually but by eventually
sometime late into this Century not
2022. so Carl let's talk about why it's
happening is this
as we were discussing earlier is this
part of Vladimir Putin's obsession with
the collapse of the Soviet Union and
this desire for
some greater Russia
I think there's a there's definitely an
extent to which that's a part of it I
think there is a distressingly pragmatic
and geographical and geopolitical reason
for the kind of the focus on Ukraine
Ukraine's position geographically there
tends to be a reason a couple of reasons
why
authoritarian leaders tend to focus on
the
um taking over other sovereign states
and that's either because they have they
occupy an extraordinarily important
strategic position
so the significance of Ukraine over the
last hundred years even before that in
terms of the access from west to east
the the Soviet desire to have a this
kind of buffer zone this distance from
Moscow to to the areas where the West
could invade
all of those things warm water ports in
Crimea there are these sort of
distressingly pragmatic reasons that
but the bottom of it mean that you that
Putin is is is the sort of leader that
that ends up treating
a Sovereign Nation as a as a as a piece
on a board
um and that's very much the kind of the
way that the sort of the grand Narrative
of of politics throughout the the Cold
War and much earlier tended to play out
where certain nations were seen not
because of their you know what they
bring although having said that Ukraine
was the Bread Basket of the Soviet Union
so you know if you have a view of the
world that lasts 100 years and you're
looking at the future of resource
conflict you know all of these things
come into play
um but at the root of it is this this
this concept of the the greater Russia
that is being created and forged
so let's look at the um key battles
there was the fight for Kiev of course
her son falling the siege of Mary upoll
battle for severo Donetsk several key
battles during the war Deborah A Lot
seemed to happen very quickly
um which battle do you think was
the most significant
I think for for me the the battle
was the most significant so far just
because that was the moment you remember
like in the run-up to the The Invasion
and even in the immediate aftermath the
widespread belief amongst government
officials and and experts in the UK and
across the West Was that Russia was this
Mighty military that would squash
Ukraine
um much as we wouldn't want to see that
and that it would be a very you know
that the Ukraine would try really hard
would fight hard
um but ultimately Russia would succeed
to some extent no one really believed
that they would manage with the force
that they'd chosen to use against this
against Ukraine that they would manage
to take the capital and conquer the
whole country
um but there was a belief that for
example the donbass would fall quickly
and and potentially parts of of the
southeast
um or the rest of the South East but I
think that the battle for Kiev showed
actually Ukraine not only wants to fight
but it can fight and as well as that it
showed the West finally after years of
absolute complacency and absolute
failure to recognize the existential
threat posed by Vladimir Putin's Russia
and to address that you know he had the
invasion of Ukraine in the beginning
back in 2014 we had the squipel
poisonings on our streets
um the multiple warning signs and yet
NATO allies the UK hadn't responded
significantly and suddenly when Putin
did act the West did respond you had not
only the sanctions but the weapons and
then the ukrainians using these weapons
effectively so effectively that you'll
remember that long column of Russian
armor that was moving slowly towards
Kiev it stopped it moved so slowly and
then it got pushed back and then that
really in terms of just the motivation
for for Ukraine and for the West to see
that it isn't impossible to beat this
giant we can do it I think that was
really key yeah it arrived very slowly
and it left a bit more quickly didn't it
Michael
um which was the significant
battle for you
well I I agree that the failure to say
key was critical to setting up the fact
that this is going to be a longer War
for me the most uh interesting battle
was Mario Paul because Mario Paul was a
a city that should have fallen within
the first 72 hours it was right on the
border of the donets People's Republic
it was a apparently a pro-russian city
before this crisis big steel works there
the other style still works on a
separate one so one of the biggest steel
areas of Europe strategically quite
important in relation to the land bridge
to Crimea and yet it didn't fall in the
first 72 hours it was three months
before it fell and the fact that it
couldn't be released the nearest
Ukrainian troops are about 60 miles away
it was clearly going to be taken
eventually but it tied up an awful lot
of Russian horses while they were trying
to take it and it was it was it was
indicative of this David and Goliath
struggle and it made a huge impression I
think on the world outside and when the
ukrainians were ordered by Q to stop
fighting the commander of the 36th uh
Marine infantry Brigade the Marines he
said think of us kindly when you think
of the Marines he said we did all that
was possible and quite a lot that was
impossible and now we're finished that
was a good line very good line and even
a couple of weeks ago in a prisoner
exchange that you and I talked about I
think the the women of avastar the
avastal steelworks had held out in the
tunnels
um endlessly it seemed the women of
Aristotle were exchanged in the prisoner
exchange and when The Exchange took
place they were coming away from the
exchange point in ranks of four they
weren't exactly marching but they were
walking in step with their heads held
high and that was the message we are the
women of avastal you better take some
notice of us we are unbowed and so I
think the the the maripole battle
although it was a it was a defeat for
the ukrainians it was the sword and
defeat upon which national mythologies
are built and the Ukraine that emerges
from this war I'm sure will be a very
different Ukraine to the Ukraine of of
2014 and certainly pre-2014. and Maria
Paul and Ava style will be two of the
symbols the defeats that mattered so
much to the spirit that the ukrainians
are now showing so very important I
think by the way if you're at home uh
hearing a rustling sound is because the
heavens have opened on the roof of the
Imperial War Museum but Deborah the the
sort of battle for Kiev that wasn't over
there was then this pushing back and we
started hearing about places like
Butcher and those other places north of
Kiev and the stories then started
emerging
of the brutality of what had happened in
the war crimes
that was really hard to it was hard to
believe
the reality of what had been done in
these places where Russian forces had
been occupying you'll remember when
after
the Russians announced this strategic
withdrawal didn't they sort of
re-shifting down into the donbass
whereas actually it was spinning the
retreat
um in the face of Ukraine's
um resistance and as they after they
were pushed back we the journalists were
able to um to move forward into these
areas and remember the journalists first
going into Butcher and seeing bodies on
the street
um this Mass grave that was found in the
grounds of of a church and then the
stories of absolute horror from the
people who had survived and evidence of
what almost seemed like
um systematic executions of certain
individuals military age males Russian
soldiers literally going from house to
house checking people's mobile phones if
they had images on the phones that they
didn't like these people might disappear
evidence of torture evidence of rape uh
horrific stories that were uh like I
said in this day and age really hard to
to report on and realize they were true
and they're still coming out stories of
different towns and Villages as they're
liberated well I think we can go now to
uh Ukraine and we have our correspondent
John Sparks who can join us I think from
Odessa there is John good evening to you
so just bring us up to date as best you
can with the the latest on this
Ukrainian counter-offensive
good evening mark look ukrainians are
still making advances but they are
incremental advances the situation is
different than what we saw in September
when they took large amounts of
territory particularly in the region of
Harkey it's much more incremental now in
the east in the South and in other
places it is a frontier a front line of
a thousand kilometers in length in other
places they are just holding the line I
mean we be speaking to commanders we've
been speaking to troops as well they
blame the weather in part the the
autumnal rains in fact they've got a
name for it bazda Raja which actually
means bad roads but they are having
trouble getting around in many of these
agricultural areas and they're waiting
they're actually waiting for winter when
movement should be easier we went to the
front lines today near Harrison at the
western side of the city of Harrison we
found the troops there dug in in
trenches and tunnels as well using this
first world war a technology actually
quite handy in terms of protecting
themselves from drones and precision
Munitions but they said look we are
making small gains not a huge amount but
they do expect at some point to be
inside the city of Harrison so
optimistic
you were there we were there together at
the beginning of the war you're there
now what's changed what's different in
your view
yeah Mark I mean I remember speaking to
you from the rooftop of a hotel in in
harkheath uh just after the Russians
started to Shell the city and I was
shocked I think like a lot of people
from Hawkeye we went to bed the night
before just simply not believing that
the Russians would would do this
and they did and and the shelling got so
close that I had to take myself off the
rooftop I think while I was actually
speaking to you so really shocked and I
think the following days the following
weeks really went in a went in a blur
for me it was very difficult to to grasp
what was happening in in many ways it's
a total tragedy it's a catastrophe in in
one way for Ukraine thousands of people
have lost their lives the World Bank has
put a price on the damage that's been
done so far of 300 billion dollars to
rebuild that's so far and as we know the
war could run for a long long time but I
think I should say I think the war has
bound this country together if there
were political questions economic
questions questions about Ukraine's
existence there aren't now I think
people are really really committed they
are ukrainians they want to live in
Ukraine it has brought this country
together
okay John John Sparks there in Odessa
thank you very much indeed well since
the summer the war has been uh
characterized by the fight back from
Ukrainian forces with Russia losing
ground uh in the East and the south of
the country uh Michael you know we've
seen you on Sky News
most nights uh bringing us analysis what
do you think the situation is now on the
ground uh particularly in the South and
the east as we speak now the Russians
have got two big pressure points to
worry about and although as John Sparks
said the the both offensives in the
Northeast and in the southwest I've
paused a little bit but they paused for
all sorts of good reasons they're going
to start in the Northeast the Russians
are trying to hold on to uh svatovay the
the town is fatova
um South to cremina and that's the the
p-66 highway since the Russians were
pushed east of the oskill river they're
holding onto that Highway as their
defense line that highway is already
under real pressure and if they lose
that Highway which I think it will then
they're probably gonna have to pull back
to starabilsk which is another 40 miles
to the East and they'll try to create
some new lines there so I think the
ukrainians are pushing and I think
they'll push the Russians a bit further
east year it before this offensive comes
to an end and in the southwest of course
it's all about Hershey and the
ukrainians have said they originally
said they'd take ocean by the end of
September they now say they'll take it
by the end of November well we'll see
but I think they will take it and they
might do it in an assault on version
from the West more likely they're moving
south from milova which they occupy
pretty well at the moment down to
novakovka which is where the Big Dam and
hydroelectric power plant is and I think
this battling herschen will be decided
by what happens at novakovka the
Russians might might blow the dam uh in
order to flood the rest of the nepro
plane uh they might in that big
catastrophe but that will dominate what
happens next but again I think that the
ukrainians will succeed I think they'll
take Noah they may take kirschen this
side of the winter but if not I think
they will definitely take it and I think
the Russians want to withdraw to the
east of the nipra river the nepro river
in order to establish more solid lines
to protect this land bridge because
ultimately if they lose lose contact
with this land bridge between the
donbass and Crimea then they've lost the
the basic rationale which they've now
established for what this war is
supposed to be all about so pivotal few
weeks ahead as winter draw I think so
and I mean Winter's miserable for
everybody in battle by and large it's it
favors the defense over the offense by
and large it's easier to hold positions
in the miserable weather than it is to
keep attacking but
um as we said the you know when the
ground is hard and armored vehicles can
move around much more easily but in
general the Russians want the winter to
come because it will make their lives a
bit easier the ukrainians want to get
something before the winter sets in but
this battle won't stop it'll just go in
go on a different Tempo during the
winter
okay Michael thanks very much indeed
well of course civilians caught up in
the war live in almost permanent fear of
attack just driving down a road at the
wrong time can be a death sentence and
after just five days of war that was
Illustrated when a Sky News team was
ambushed by an advanced party of Russian
soldiers their car destroyed as they
came under sustained machine gun fire
Stuart Ramsey was shot in the lower back
the bullet passing through his body with
his body armor taking six more rounds
this is what happened
okay okay
what the [ __ ]
everyone
where is everyone
here
stop
British journalist s
British journalists journalista
[Music]
well us Stuart Ramsey joins us now from
Sao Paulo in Brazil where he's been
covering the elections going on there
and Stuart it's good to talk to you
um and I mean that Ambush I gather you
went back to uh Ukraine to the scene of
that Ambush tell us what that was like
and of course it just gives people an
idea of the kind of thing that civilians
are putting up with in Ukraine day in
Day Out
yeah firstly that's really important to
actually Mark and that's really why that
report is important and why it was filed
because we were on the m06 which is the
Western approach uh to Kiev
um the investigators into what they
consider to be a crime against us by by
the Russians
um would they believe that the Russians
intended that to be the main way for
their tanks that we were talking about
that huge column that that was the way
they were going to try to get into the
uh to the city now the m06 they needed
cleared we're one of the first cars that
were unfortunate enough to be ambushed
but there were dozens more over the next
uh sort of a campaign we think uh of
about two weeks and lots of civilians
um were either killed or certainly
injured we did go back it was quite
strange going back uh to the bridge that
we basically stopped on and we had to
drive underneath it because they'd found
a way through it had been blown
um that's why we first really came to a
stop
um and then we went to see where where
our car was the police took took us away
and there were literally hundreds of
cars that had been destroyed by the
Russians and they were in there so it
was all it was quite an experience to go
back and see it I have to say Mark you
know listening to the audio of it just
then
um it is always quite depressing I
cannot believe
um that we were able to escape from that
vehicle the point being of course is
that hey we do quite a lot of training
and we're all wearing body armor the
difference for the civilians families
which we know were killed is that they
are not trained and they're not wearing
any body armor and so once those bullets
and rounds start coming in you know
they're going to die and that is why we
were fortunate that's why we lived and
this was happening in number a number of
locations there had been reports a
couple of days before that this was
happening but this got this was an
indicator that the Russians were and
will continue to attack civilians if
they get in their way as Stuart you've
spent uh the past decade really
reporting from uh Ukraine before uh the
fall of Crimea you reported uh down in
the south and east uh quite a lot also
the Georgian and Chechen Wars uh you
covered have Russian tactics in your
view changed at all
I know they they certainly haven't well
in the early part and the way that that
sort of violence that you saw that we
got caught up in and what happened in
butcher was sort of different but if you
look at the the the the the use of heavy
weapons like like we used to see in
grossly where they just basically
flattening towns well we saw that in
mariopol and it's exactly the same
tactic that they've used before and I
haven't seen an awful lot of uh of
change one of the things I found
um being in chechnya with the Russians
um as well as the Chechen separatists
that they weren't very good and
um I think we all thought I think
Deborah was saying that earlier that
everyone assumed that the Russians had
actually built themselves up and that
they were now better equipped and that
they would be able to pretty much
Steamroller The ukrainians out of the
way what's quite clear that to me at
least is the tactics hadn't changed and
in fact quite a lot of their kit hadn't
changed either and they're actually not
very well organized either we know for
example that there are communication
systems in the early part of the war
failed almost instantly and they were
using Ukrainian mobile phones which of
course and Russian mobile phones which
the ukrainians could identify so they
weren't very good but that tactic of
just basically smashing up a town and
then moving forward they're still doing
and they did it in Chechen and they're
doing it now okay Stuart thanks very
much indeed we'll let you get on with
your uh work in Brazil thank you very
much
let's have a a look in a little more
detail at uh what has happened so far
during this war if you want to do that
go to the Sky News website or app there
you can see a detailed timeline of the
key events and also watch Sky news
reports from the front line in our
Ukraine war interactive you can also
scan the QR code on the screen right now
to go to it think of it as a sort of
digital exhibition the likes of which
you may see here at the Imperial War
Museum in years to come
now he may be a somewhat divisive figure
here in Britain but to the people of
Ukraine Boris Johnson is held in high
esteem so much so that he was awarded
its highest civilian honor for foreign
Nationals the order of Liberty he was
the first G7 leader to visit Kiev after
the end of The Siege following Russia's
Invasion and has spoken repeatedly about
the importance of British support for
Ukraine but what were those early days
of the invasion really like and does he
have any regrets I sat down with the
former prime minister this afternoon
here at the Imperial War Museum for an
exclusive interview
Boris Johnson Vladimir Putin thought
that this war would be over in days in a
week or so yeah did you fear the same
that was certainly the advice that we
were getting and the some of the defense
intelligence people were saying look
this is going to be very very one-sided
the Russians are just going to roll
through and uh numerically they're so
strong and they said well so well
equipped I'd been to Ukraine a few times
before and I kind of knew that they were
going to fight and if you you've been
there a lot and you talked to people who
fought in the Eastern in donbass since
2014 these are hardened hardened
Fighters so I thought it would be much
tougher than uh than than Putin thought
do you think that now they could be on
the verge of victory
I think it's absolutely inevitable that
the ukrainians will eventually win I'll
tell you why because this is a war of
independence and Wars of Independence
only really end one way and the crucial
thing for for us all who believe in this
cause who believe that the cause of
Ukrainian freedom is
all of our calls we just have to show
strategic patience and continue to
support them Victory look like what does
it beyond what does that Victory look
like there I think the exact Contours of
victory are very much up to the
ukrainians we can't be more Ukrainian
than the ukrainians passionately though
we may support them it's up to them it's
up to Vladimir zielinski to decide I
would have thought that it's going to be
very difficult for anything to be
acceptable that stops short of a full
return of all the areas
taken by the Russians since uh February
the 24th uh this year right so could you
see any solution that allowed Putin to
keep Crimea and and
all or most of the annexed areas
no frankly I think well I think Crimea
is a slightly separate issue and but
it's again it's for the ukrainians it's
not for us to to decide
do you think that Vladimir Putin is
running out of options
I think that
Putin disastrously
miscalculated and a we kind of in the UK
government we all read his crackers
essay on Ukraine
summer of last year and we could see
that he he fundamentally misunderstood
what Ukraine is it was like reading
Slobodan milosevic on on the subject of
of Kosovo which I'm sure you remember
well uh slobo basically thought Kosovo
was an integral part of a greater Serbia
and the spiritual Homeland uh the
origins of uh of the Serb uh nation and
I think that's how Putin thought about
kievan Russ and and the origins of uh
the Orthodox faith and and all the rest
of it and it's a total category error
Ukraine is an in a free independent
European culture with its own identity
uh its own Ambitions its own destiny and
he made a fundamental mistake and so you
know he's he's but if he is fighting
nationalism and that but if he's running
out of options my point was about him
being cornered there's a lot of talk
about
tactical nuclear weapons do you think do
you think he would use them well first
of all let me just let's look at this
this your phrase and he's running out of
options and he has uh you know as a
limit to what he could he can do don't
forget Mark he's still overwhelmingly
supported by you know whether we believe
he's opinion puzzle well it's pretty
clear that he's supported by the vast
bulk of uh the Russian people
um yes there's a bit of kind of fraying
now in the in the media coverage and and
I'm not saying it'd be easy for him but
there is a world in which he can say to
the Russian people look we had a special
operation
we needed to denoxify Ukraine we needed
to make sure that uh it wasn't a Haven
for anti-russian feeling that the
Russian minorities were treated properly
and the Russian language was protecting
so we've achieved that
so I mean I think there is an option it
may sound crazy but I think there is an
option where he could and hold on to the
places he's taken like her son that will
he will I don't think that's credible
for him anymore he will lose those
his position is he will not want to lose
those and my question was do you fear
that he could use a tactical Nuclear I
don't I don't think he I don't think he
will I I think he'd be crazy to to do so
conflict if he did I think what would
happen is that he would immediately
tender Russia's resignation from the
club of civilized Nations it would be a
total disaster for his country so the
the current economic punishment that the
West has been able to dish out would be
massively intensified Russia would be
put into a kind of cryogenic economic
freeze and I think he would lose a lot
of the kind of Middle Ground of of
global uh tacit
acquiescence that he's had I mean if you
look at sub-Saharan Africa you look at
Latin America look at Lula for instance
uh who's just been elected again
look at South Asia
there's there's a lot of of willingness
to give Putin the benefit of the doubt
that will go the minute he does anything
uh like that he would also crucially I
think lose the patronage of the Chinese
and above all in his own country I think
he would trigger an absolutely
hysterical uh reaction so I don't think
that is a real military response would
there be a military response it'd have
to be a military response I think the
crucial thing about uh strategic nuclear
deterrence and the logic of it is you
don't talk about what you would do but
clearly there would have to be a
response of some kind but it wouldn't
have to be nuclear it could be a it
could be a very large conventional
response forces in Ukraine would that be
something that he should expect there
are all sorts of options that I know
I mean we've talked about both in uh in
NATO and then in the P3 the uh the the
Western nuclear powers of talk have
talked about uh that would clearly have
to be a response but as I say I don't
think it's going to I think it's very
very very very unlikely that it'll come
back I I I think it's important
that we don't as it will waste too much
time on this conversation because this
is the this is exactly how Putin wants
to frame it he wants to frame it as a
standoff between a nuclear-armed Russia
and a nuclear-armed NATO that's what
that's that's how he wants to to present
it it's not so you know a brutal
Invasion it's about a brutal invasion of
an innocent country by conventional
means and what we are providing is the
conventional support that will enable
the ukrainians to win see I just wonder
how dangerous a moment you think this is
for the world
I think that this is a critical moment
for the world and I think it's a pivotal
moment it's a turning point and I think
the danger is that we will try to
compromise and uh find some sort of deal
some grubby bargain with uh with Putin
try to encourage the ukrainians to trade
some of their their territory which will
only encourage Putin to make
you know further further aggression as
we've seen since 2014 and but the prize
for holding firm and continuing to
support Ukraine is absolutely immense
because For the First Time in decades
we'll have shown that we really believe
in democracy and freedom and that we're
really willing to support it so I want
to talk those values in Europe I want to
talk to a Ukrainian Victory could be an
absolute turning point for the world
just a final point on the nuclear threat
how much time has prime minister did you
worry
about
the possibility that Vladimir Putin May
um use a nuclear weapon well for the
reason reasons Mark that I've given I
think it's very important that we don't
allow the whole debate to be framed in
those in those terms because that's what
you know he's like the fact that the fat
boy in Dickens he wants to make our
flesh creep right uh he wants he wants
to Spook everybody out with this
conversation uh I think it's far more
important that we concentrate on the
ways in which militarily uh
diplomatically economically we can
ensure that the ukrainians
see the Russians of right get them out
of their territory and and build an
independent future now Ukraine is
clearly personal to you it clearly means
a lot
um I just wonder why is that
I was very lucky I became a foreign
secretary in 2016 and one of the first
things I did was go to Ukraine and I
remember
talking to ukrainians who've been
fighting in in donbass and I remember
getting to see the this Great Wall uh
where they have I think I'm sure you
you've seen it many times yourself the
the the pictures of the thousands and
thousands of Ukrainian uh soldiers
who've given their lives for uh for the
freedom and Independence of their
country
and I became very sympathetic to their
cause and I remember standing on on you
know on that beautiful Acropolis in uh
in Kiev and talking about uh the
possibility
that Russia might be so insane as to
take advantage of the fact that there
was no security guarantee to Ukraine
because Ukraine was not given
NATO membership and clearly it was a
problem because my point is and that is
that is what we now have to fix but my
point is that one minute you were
leading the world's response to Ukraine
in many ways the next minute
you know you were out of Downing Street
and out of power how did that feel
I think that thankfully the the UK has
got an absolutely seamless continuity of
of policy and uh Rishi I know had an
excellent talk the other night with uh
with Vladimir zielinsky and we are going
to continue flat out to to support
Ukraine and and to make sure that we're
there and give them everything they need
now if I can make a plug for what I
think they need now I talked to a friend
in in Kiev last night and
um as you know the the lights are out
there's no there's no water they're
having to queue for for bottled water
because they're getting these missile
attacks on their electricity facilities
and it's absolutely inhumane what the
Ukraine is now need and we've given them
lots of great stuff from starting with
the anti-tank gun the anti-tank missiles
uh what they need is is more
anti-aircraft okay and ideally they need
fixed-wing aircraft to take to take out
the drones and the missiles but you
don't regret losing that influence and
losing that power because it in many
ways look it was your own mistakes you
made and that deprived you of the
influence and the power that you had
over Ukraine you must regret that
because that was something that yes I
mean tempting as it is to that the the
most important thing is to uh Focus not
on you know me or my political career
well to focus on on what matters
is turfing out prime ministers the right
thing to be doing in the middle of a the
worst crisis the worst conflict since
the second world war in Europe I think
the important thing is for all of us uh
particularly in the United States to
remain focused on the needs of the
Ukrainian people and if I if I may say
so the UK you're kind of what you said
about the the role of the UK and I think
it's true we did play an important part
uh particularly in the beginning but
actually throughout in in bringing our
friends together in organizing those
great
um uh yeah you know what businesses
The crucial thing is is in North America
is it the vice
our American friends are making me I
want to do that just finally on this
zelenski was your friend he is your
friend very fond of you they're even
naming a street after you in a sense
didn't you let them down by by I think
the mistakes that led to you leaving
office I see what you mean look uh I
certainly uh want to do everything I can
to help Ukraine and that's always been
um you know my my commitment I've said
that to uh to Vladimir irrespective of
whether I'm in in office I think there
are ways I can be I could I can be
useful
um
for instance how would you be I think
it's very important that the
um
America has been extraordinary Joe Biden
has been absolutely wonderful and you
know but people may not expect me to say
that but I I think he he
America as so often massively surprised
on the upside I mean 44 45 billion
dollars two and a half million dollars
worth of uh military equipment the the
high Mars the uh the the rocket systems
to take out uh
ukrainians couldn't take out Russian
Munitions who win the midterm elections
take over Congress and they are saying
there is no blank check for Ukraine
correct that's why I I thought that's
what uh my old friend Kevin McCarthy
said the other day and I I you know I
think that actually when you talk to
individual Republicans they see the the
vital importance of this of this
struggle uh but yeah if I can be useful
in trying to get over to people
why I see this as such an absolutely
critical test of of Western will uh that
I think that'd be a good thing to do but
it's it's America that is is crucial
America has given so much of the
military Sports much of the economic
support but do you worry that that may
now Wane I think you've all you've
always got to be
you know it's a lot to ask of any
country particularly in tough Economic
Times and the Americans have been
fantastic I mean the UK has given a huge
amount as well we'll be given a huge
amount of money huge amount of military
assistance but do you see any future
British government going soft on Ukraine
even even you know on the persuading
zielinski towards negotiations or
persuading him to do a deal
I I would argue
passionately against that and just for
this reason that I don't think and I
don't think it's likely to happen but I
I just don't think it's realistic
because there's no deal that zielinski
can do and there's no deal that Putin is
offering there were reports that Rishi
sunak was trying to limit the amount of
money that you were
um giving to Ukraine and the amount of
support that you were giving to Ukraine
is that true I think the the the UK's
support has been uh I was going to say a
second but not between second to the
Americans otherwise it's been it's been
it's been so he never tried to uh we've
had we've had we've given uh a huge
amount of financial support and I think
the decisive thing that we did was to to
read it early and read it right and to
help them with particularly with the the
end laws the anti-tank weapons in the in
the early days those were very but given
the
um constraints that there may now be on
government spending do you fear a
curtailment a limiting of the resources
going to Ukraine my no I think that the
uh well obviously there's a there's a
practical limit on on what we can give
both in Munitions and and financial
support but we will continue to I've
absolutely no doubt uh the conservative
government will continue to be very
supportive and very generous because
this is this issue they commit to the
history because they thought this is
pivotal for our our future do you think
they should commit to the three percent
of GDP I think on defense spending by
2030 I think it is I think I I think I
pointed out that under uh under our
current commitments were good I think
we're already at 2.4 uh we're going to
go to 2.5
uh uh just you know we continue with uh
with orcas and uh and F Cass and the
future combat aircraft system and
various other things we're going to
spend a huge amount on defense what
about whatever happens what about the
commitment to the British public a poll
We Have Tonight suggests people are
committed to support Ukraine but that
support weakens significant if it means
higher energy bills what would you say
to the British public I think I I really
understand people's uh
pain or anxiety about energy prices and
the the misery of everybody's being been
going through but I would just say to
people that this is a chance for us in
the UK actually in the whole of the the
Western World to get through get off our
dependence on Russian hydrocarbons and
build a more secure future for ourselves
in which we rely on our own uh domestic
production of renewable energy or indeed
nuclear energy and and have a totally
different future so the truth is and
this is why I'm very optimistic about
what's happening I think that actually
with every week and every month that
goes by we become more resilient more
capable of providing for our energy
needs and less dependent in the future
on on Vladimir Putin um how worried are
you that Russia hacked the personal
mobile of your foreign secretary
um and quite possibly got details of
dealings with Ukraine you know we never
talk about security issues
but I mean that must be a worrying thing
that happened in your
government we never talk about security
issues as you know is that why it was
surprised you didn't say anything about
it at the time it wasn't it but Mark
you're guilty of what's called potitio
principia you'll bet you're asking me to
uh to discuss something which I've said
I won't discuss and that we don't we
don't talk about security okay so
finally you would like to stay involved
with Ukraine what kind of have you
spoken to Rishi suneck about a role a
possible role I think what I can do and
what I will want to do is to continue to
to Champion the cause of Ukrainian
freedom of a free Sovereign independent
Ukraine it is a great cause I think it's
a cause that has mobilized a phenomenal
level of support across the UK would you
like a formal role I mean do you see it
I'm happy with doing what I'm doing kind
of envoy right I think I think you know
this is this is my job is to to talk up
what I think are the immediate needs of
the Ukraine is if I just repeat that
that key point for our our viewers I
think what I'm sure you'll you're
brilliant correspondence you've done by
the way are fantastic job throughout
this uh throughout this this War I think
what they would what they would agree
with they need more help in in taking
out those those drones and those
missiles will you go back to Ukraine uh
inevitably but uh I'm not saying I'll
let you know before I go but yeah last
two um do you feel more appreciated on
the world stage than you do domestically
yeah and is that is that one of the
reasons you're going to go to cop 27.
um I have a
absolute passionate belief that uh the
war in Ukraine Putin's Act of aggression
is something that we shouldn't accept
and shouldn't tolerate
um I I think that I can continue to
campaign for Ukraine uh out of office
and that's what I'm gonna do are you
going to go to cop 27
yes as it happens but um that's
that's not relevant to Ukraine and final
question I mean do you still Harbor
Homes I was invited by his invited by
the by the Egyptian son thank you and
you presumably think the Prime Minister
should go I know I think the the premise
is doing uh as as he's pointed out he's
got a massive amount to do we've got to
sort out uh a huge
agenda and that's what he's getting on
with
um I happen to have a particular I was
at the Glasgow cop although it's become
unfashionable to talk about it was a
fantastic Global success we did a huge
amount of good for the planet I want to
talk a little bit about uh how uh I see
things and how we see things in the UK
and do you still Harbor hopes of
returning as prime minister is it
unfinished business
Mark you promised this was going to be
about Ukraine I I Harbor hopes of
continued campaign for uh for Ukraine
and that is my priority and there are
various other things I'm doing but that
is of course it's very dear to my heart
Boris Johnson thank you thank you
Boris Johnson there let's get the views
of our panel uh on that into Deborah
what did you make of what he had to say
well yes he is the former prime minister
but his words on Ukraine count because
of that uniquely special relationship
that he had his still has with Vladimir
zielinski I mean the fact is that when
Russia launched its Invasion on the 24th
of February the very first foreign
leader who the Ukrainian president
picked up the phone to was our British
prime minister and he also chose before
the war started he chose to support
Ukraine and the UK like you said was
this leading voice that Not only was was
actually actively putting in weapons
itself was also pressuring European
allies and crucially was pressuring the
United States yes Joe Biden has acted
very strongly and given huge significant
overwhelming support to Ukraine but that
wasn't guaranteed and I think the fact
that you had a British prime minister
that was so forward-leaning right early
on
um moved moved away any avoidance of of
doubt and confusion on the U.S side and
you saw the U.S as well acting so the UK
played this fundamentally important
leadership role under Boris Johnson
whatever you think of him domestically
and there is a concern regardless of
what Boris Johnson might say about this
seamless support for for Ukraine of the
UK government that under a new leader
that special chemistry won't be any
there anymore and what will happen then
I want to talk to the Ukrainian
Ambassador in just a moment about what
Boris was saying but Michael just pick
up on this issue that Boris Johnson
seemed very concerned about which is
this you know ongoing commitment as a
difficult winter draws in for many
European countries when it comes to
energy and so forth yeah I mean from
here on in it gets much tougher it felt
tough already but actually from here on
in it gets harder for the West because
we've now got to maintain these
consensus which has been considerable
it's been it's surprised most of us to
be honest but it gets harder as we go
through the winter if we get to the
other side of the winter then it'll be
an awful lot easier because the pendulum
really will start moving against Russia
at that point and back towards Ukraine
in a I think a more fundamental military
sense notwithstanding the fact that the
Russians will undoubtedly launch a big
second offensive probably in the spring
but getting through the winter is a
tough thing it's been astonishing in a
way I you know I was writing at the time
that the it's a new world since Thursday
when we had the The Invasion and Europe
has remade itself that there was the EU
engaging in sanctions powerful sanctions
that nobody thought they would do
Nordstrom 2 was off the table nobody
thought we'd do that there was the
United States playing the transit
transatlantic role it was Britain
playing its traditional role which we
feel that we're good at as a bridge
between the Europeans and the other
Europeans and the United States NATO was
was remarkably consensual remarkably
effective all of a sudden Europe and the
transatlantic relationship was working
the way it was supposed to work and I
was saying to myself this is wonderful
how long will it last well it's lasted
longer than we thought because the
political leaderships are still in
locked step with each other but they've
not really come under concerted domestic
pressure now it may happen in the United
States after the midterm elections next
week it may start to happen in Germany
and France as the winter really bites
it's certainly happening in southern
Europe where things are different in
Hungary and Greece and Cyprus and so on
they take different views
um but Britain is along with the North
European Britain Poland Denmark Estonia
Latvia Lithuania the Scandinavians
Canada the United States this is a new
sort of North European transatlantic
NATO it might turn out to be the core of
a new note I don't know but those
Northern countries are holding the
consensus together so it's really
important what Boris said there it turns
out to be true that he has set a role
and history will whatever this whatever
history says about it and I think it
should be pretty harsh on him on most
things but on this history will be fair
to him and it'll be kind to him because
on this he's separate and in a direction
which I think will help to influence
everybody else okay uh in the audiences
the Ukrainian ambassador of Adam
prostago good evening to you I just
wonder what uh you made of what what
struck you about what Boris Johnson had
to say
nothing struck me actually because we
had these conversations and with the
Prime Minister as well and you
remembered that he was not just coming
three times through the war in Ukraine
he actually came just before the war
which allowed us to to you know to have
an open conversation adult conversation
between President zelinski and prime
minister and as she prepared us we
received this anti-tank rocket just on
time because this conversation happened
and I have to tell you that he is right
that he had a personal attachment to
Ukraine I have to remind you that the
previous prime minister is
the last one bilateral came in 1996 so
we didn't have much of the cooperation
between UK and Ukraine suddenly just
because of his we just got lucky that we
have this particular person being a
prime minister of us but at the same
time we understand that he's just a
spearhead of the whole effort of the
whole you know I was trying to explain
to ukrainians many many times why UK is
so supportive I hear in this series that
you support in Fair case but so many
nations do I know that you're supporting
underdogs but there are some Nations
also doing a very difficult to explain
to Ukraine's but even the notion of
Underdog we don't even have the word
specific to this term but actually
that's because the UK came to us and so
many nations you know where came
afterwards being sorry developed
coordinated and helped I believe that
many prime minister says no this is
conversation I understand discussion
whether somebody will be on the level of
prime minister Johnson I don't believe
the ukrainians will have a choice and a
cake of Boris Johnson named after Boris
Johnson but that's what we expect your
new Prime Ministers to find something
better than Just Cakes behind after them
has Rishi seen that given you any
commitments which is something just a
very recent addition to your Prime
ministerial sort of
leadership I hope that sometime this
trust will come because she was very
instrumental as a foreign secretary she
has this role to play I hope that she
will be playing I don't believe that all
prime minister have to play the same
role but the new prime minister the most
important part has been discussed
already how much money you will be able
to set aside from your own internal
problems which I am respectfully
difficult to understand that too okay
Ambassador thanks very much we'll see
what Liz trust gets up to next but if um
there's anybody in the audience who
wants to make a point about what they've
just heard what Boris Johnson was saying
or I want to ask a question to the panel
please think about that now
um we'll take those questions in just a
second I just want to ask Carl the whole
point during that interview of the you
know possibility of put in using some
sort of technical nuclear weapon the
fact even fact we're having this
conversation
in the 21st century kind of beggar's
belief
it does I think the the most interesting
thing is how these conversations fit
into the wider pattern of messages and
signals sent and received so we have a
tendency I think to think about when we
ask journalistic questions of former
Prime Ministers that that
somehow we're we're not taking part in
that world of messages sent and received
what I think you heard there if you
think about an anniversary that we've
just gone gone through the Cuban Missile
Crisis for example so a few days ago
very fortunately 60 years ago a few days
ago the Cuban Missile Crisis ended if
you think what we know now about the
level of
conversation the kind of the multiple
levels of signal sent and received
either both overtly through the media
through journalists through making sort
of you know statements that were kind of
approved not approved for things that we
know now about those kind of
efforts to avoid what John F Kennedy
called you know the the danger of
accident miscalculation or Madness which
would be you know that would be one of
the one of the three reasons why we'd be
plunging to into nuclear disaster
I think it's really interesting when you
hear somebody interviewed who was in a
position and is now sort of having a
slightly different position
to think about why
why
things are said in a certain way and how
that will
in 10 20 30 years when we have a greater
understanding of what's going on behind
the scenes in the Diplomatic back
channels Jake Sullivan talked about at
the Pentagon
um that's where we'll start to see
exactly what the meaning of of
conversations like the the one you just
had wasn't I think it'll be fascinating
to see okay Carl thanks very much so is
there anybody who wants to make a point
at this stage in proceedings or Mark
Francois
foreign
on the House of Commons defense
Committee just to back up what Deborah
said about warnings from Britain and the
U.S on the 6th of January a debate took
place in the House of Commons on Russian
strategy and in that a number of members
of the committee both conservative and
labor effectively predicted that Russia
was likely to invade we we never got the
date and the time that we said they can
really do this so people already in
Parliament
were calling for attention to what might
happen we were laughed at we were said
that we were a bunch of hawks you're all
soldiers you always say that the
Russians are coming well in the words of
Nigel farage they're not laughing now
and I think In fairness to Boris
whatever people think of his domestic
record he has provided leadership among
European NATO Nations
on this issue I think ably supported by
people like Liz trust and Ben Wallace
who I think has played a Blinder as a
defense secretary
and I think Britain has paid a
fundamental role in supporting the
people of Ukraine not just militarily
but also if you like morally and
bringing the world's attention to the
barbaric Russian invasion so hopefully
we have done our bit and will continue
to do so and that includes spending
three percent of GDP on defense yeah
okay Mark thanks very much anybody with
a question they would like to put to the
panel or anything like say yes sir
um
what if uh shooting we hear a lot of
things that he's ill what if he doesn't
care about the future and he just
decides um
drop the bomb
that's how I want to be remembered
okay well look this is a an interesting
question you bring up Vladimir Putin I
think we can go to Moscow in fact to try
and get a view from Moscow do we have
the screen I don't I'm sure the screen's
working but I think that we can talk to
Diana Magna in Moscow is that right
Diana good evening and uh thank you and
we've just had a question about what
really comes down to I suppose you know
the rationality of of Vladimir Putin I
mean what is the feeling
in Moscow what are Russian people
thinking on that issue
well I I don't think Vladimir Putin is
mad he is a rational actor
um and therefore there are many things
that he may be trying to carve out for
his legacy such as getting back as much
of Ukraine as he can but leaving a
nuclear Legacy if he doesn't absolutely
have to I don't think and I don't think
many people here think that he is
prepared to do I think Vladimir Putin
understands the value of a nuclear
Arsenal is not in using it is it is in
its deterrent factor and so all the way
along we've heard angria nuclear
rhetoric when his army is doing worse
and different messaging when it's not
um and you know if you look at Russian
military Doctrine for example on how to
manage de-escalate and escalate
conflicts you'll see that they talk
about using conventional non-nuclear
strikes say on infrastructure which
we're seeing across Ukraine at the
moment coupled with nuclear threats
coupled complemented with the threat of
using a possible tactical nuclear weapon
and that that is the way of trying to
calibrate how your adversary will
respond to you and I think that Putin is
trying to do that and it will depend on
how things go on the battlefield because
I think the assessment in Western
capitals at the beginning of this war
was that the likelihood of nuclear
disaster was much smaller than it is now
because the assessment was that the
Russian army would perform much better
than it seems to have done and we'll
have to see how the winter goes you know
the latest messaging from Vladimir Putin
was essentially a message to the global
South saying it is the West who's using
nuclear blackmail against us I would I'm
not a big bad nasty guy I would never
use it but I think if that that is a
message for China India to suggest that
it's the West at fault here and for his
own people but I think if he feels
um really backed into a corner and if
his troops are facing a catastrophe he
might be pushed to other mechanisms
because I think fundamentally the point
of the nuclear threat is to try and
force either the ground in Ukraine to be
Frozen as it is or that the worst forces
of Vladimir zielinski to sit down and
talk which would be Madness for Ukraine
now seeing as it is gaining ground on
the battlefield and Dinah we hear a lot
talk a lot about what ukrainians are
thinking about the progress of this war
what a what a
Russians thinking what are muscovites
thinking about the way things are going
well they know now that it's not going
according to plan which is was the
messaging throughout the first five
months really
um but you know you hear these mantras
uh today I heard it again what was Putin
to do for eight long years the children
of Don bass have been bombarded that
kind of messaging that they get from
State TV all the time the decision to
declare partial mobilization and say
send 300 000 young Russian men to fight
has come as a significant shock but it
hasn't necessarily turned people against
this War uh it has just brought the war
home to them
um and you know
I don't need to tell you how compelling
and how hypnotic really State TV is and
how much it affects the national psyche
here and of course there are
parties on each end who don't accept
that messaging and who don't really want
to have a part in any of this and the
percentages on each side of that may be
moving but essentially the middle ground
of people here are on Putin's side they
think it is the West who's at fault for
this entire situation they know it's all
going according to plan but to a certain
extent it's it's causing them to to say
well you know we're all in
um I don't think yet you're seeing some
sort of turn in people's mood here
there's just increasing worry increasing
anxiety increasing concern okay uh
interesting stuff Diana thank you very
much for being with us now when I was in
Ukraine the foreign minister there said
something very interesting to me he said
Ukraine was fighting a 21st century War
and the Russians he said were stuck in
the World War II trenches in truth the
war in Ukraine has been a conventional
conflict fought by troops in close
combat backed by tanks and missile
strikes but many factors also make this
a modern war with intelligence and
information
reshaping the battle line so let's talk
about uh this and Michael it in what
ways do you think this is a
a different War a modern war well it's
modern and in the sense that it it
covers the whole Spectrum so uh the
ukrainians are critically dependent on
starlink starlink
organization Elon Musk which is exactly
Elon musk's put 3000 satellites there
which provide an unbreakable Battlefield
communication system which uh the
ukrainians can use and so at the one hat
in the one hand this is space wars
already important in our world we all
knew they would be this is the first
example where it matters and then on the
other hand we're talking about good
old-fashioned deep down and dirty
Logistics the ability of troops to cope
with the mud uh the ability of vehicles
to move over wet ground all the sort of
things that are not just our fathers but
our grandfathers would have remembered
from the walls of the of the 20th
century so in a way this is a war that
is that is as we thought Wars would in
the future stretch the conception of
warfare but both to the as it were to
the top and to the bottom we didn't
think we would see it in a high Tempo
war in Europe we thought we'd see the
little bits of it in Wars around the
world different sorts of Wars about
different things but here is an all-out
war with one side struggling for its
survival and the other side determined
to do whatever it takes not to lose
whether or not the Russians really think
they can win now but they are determined
not to lose and in that situation we're
seeing a war which is is unique it's
it's and interestingly we're seeing now
the ukrainians do what the British
forces are telling themselves they will
have to train to do the Ukraine is
actually doing it there every day in and
day out what on Salisbury Plain or at
Shriver at the uh defense concept Center
they're saying we've got to learn to do
all these things the ukrainians are
doing it very soon we we talk about
training them very soon they'll be
training us
Deborah I want to talk to you about the
drones because you saw I think a drone
team firsthand but Carl for just very
briefly pick up the point that Michael
made I mean in many ways this is about
traditional
Warfare the hard slog of War yeah and
you know that there is a fundamental
truth about Warfare in the you know it
it really ends with the the use of
kinetic weapons on soft human flesh you
know that's that's what we've been
seeing over the last
um the last few months that's the the
reason that we see these images on our
screens and the reason that they are so
distressingly familiar is because at the
very sharp end there are basically two
battlefields that are attempting to be
won there's the battlefield on the
ground and of course there's the the
battlefield in people's minds which is
the other area where we now see all of
these sort of Innovations into the
hybrid Warfare in terms of the way in
which the social media is co-opted and
all these kind of things but
fundamentally it's attempting to do the
same thing it's attempting to to win
effectively a kind of spin War both at
home and abroad and then win a very
traditional war on the battlefield which
involves
um the creation of of loss you know
Peter Taylor talked about this in
Northern Ireland the common denominator
is loss
I mean this social media there's almost
a social media Army in Ukraine I mean
that you know these civilians portraying
what's happened to them
um uh as you know sort of stalwart
survivors the Russians or the aggressors
it had does have an impact on social
media it's often picked up by a
journalist and it's the speed with which
that sort of information is transmitted
that's different not necessarily the
fact that that information is you know
people desire that information to get
out you know there used to be that the
Reliance was on journalists it used to
be that the Reliance was on letters home
the types of things that we have in our
collection but the way that that
permeated into the Consciousness was
much much longer and now of course it's
it's a very rapid and evolving daily
thing but I mean critically about war
crimes because at one time your war
crimes evidence was kept was captured
after the fact bit of an afterthought
now from day one there is evidence war
crimes and that evidence is there in the
digital archives it'll be there forever
it'll be there in 50 years time it'll be
there in 100 years time it cannot be
burned it cannot be destroyed it's there
from day one but it's a very interesting
point and there's so much of this stuff
I should just say there's so much of
this stuff that the whole question of
what is real what is true uh verifying
this stuff I mean we have a unit at Sky
News that is constantly examining data
and analyzing pictures to make sure they
are what they say I mean that is a
really important part of this but I I
don't know what it was you wanted to say
but drones I want to just get because
you did spend time with a drone team and
drones have played a an interesting part
in this War I will just say my little
thing if that's okay
um I think it's really important about
how the Ukrainian military has used
social media as well and and on the
Russian side and there's so many
um sort of catchy little videos that the
Ukrainian defense Ministries Twitter
feed pumps out
um that again it's part of the it's the
influence operation that is another
dimension in Warfare and the ukrainians
are Masters at it in terms of shaping
The Narrative when you had the um the
counter-offensive that was launched on
the 29th of August in the South against
Hassan and then against harkiv
um the ukrainians completely shut down
the front line to journalists they
absolutely blocked anyone getting
um approved access and instead the only
images that we really saw were those
that were released by Ukrainian soldiers
as part of that offensive and it was in
a powerful way of controlling the
narrative controlling what we're seeing
and a difference in the drones in a
minute but there's a difference in
approach between
zelenski you know these nightly
addresses to the people of Ukraine and
the impact that has and Putin on his
long table who's the long table the you
know the speeches once or twice every
month or something long spear I mean
there's a big difference
remember when um Vladimir zielinski made
his first big press conference after the
the
subject around Keith would be had beated
and he'd obviously he's obviously like
you know do you remember he was told at
the beginning by the Americans to get
the hell out of Kiev and he was like
give me bullets not a ride
um he was a want he is a wanted man
there's a big Target on his head and yet
he suddenly appeared in this underground
station in the center of Kiev with this
huge kind of media crew with like
cameras everywhere
um and he came sort of like walking down
this um elevator and there's all of us
journalists kind of sitting out we all
had little signs to kind of pop up if we
wanted a question and he sat there and
he fielded questions for about two and a
half hours it was incredible and it's
all about information it's all about
influencing it's using that information
to convince Western leaders to keep on
giving weapons to Ukraine when their own
populations are suffering it is such an
important part of this world we can talk
about drones very quickly drones yeah so
trains
um it's it's fascinating fascinating for
me as a defense journalist that's
covered defense for a long time spent
time in different War zones uh to to you
hear about about the use of drones and
they have become such a fundamental
weapon in the war yes there's lots of
elements of battle trenches tanks
artillery and yet you suddenly have for
the first time really in this kind of
comprehensive way drones being used to
call in our artillery strikes to pick
out targets we're talking a bit about
cyber as well like the UK today
revealing
um the support the secret support that
it's been given to Ukraine to fend off a
massive cyber war that we don't see but
is going on and how the the Russians are
using for example getting into CCTV
networks to be able to see where targets
are using that to then call in strikes
to hit targets and obviously the
ukrainians are doing that um in return
it's it's a sophisticated
um but also very simple way if you think
about it drones you can get them very
cheaply they are pumping these things
out the for the head of the armed forces
are military Chief said the other day
um that the UK has given something like
30 different types of drone to Ukraine
as it tests which ones are best and
these are uh you know it's leveling the
playing field but also it's very scary
and you said like being out in in like a
sort of Frontline area in kharkiv
hearing that sound of a drone overhead
and knowing that artillery could then be
pulled into your position it's pretty
frightening Mark we've got we've got
loads of air power expertise in the
first couple of rows of the audience and
they know they know very well that you
can have you can spend billions of
dollars on air superiority as we've done
for 50 or 60 years but from now on you
will never control the air the air space
below 5000 feet because that's the
that's where the drones go and so you
can play for air superiority they all
know it but below 5000 feet belongs to
the drones okay Michael thanks very much
thank you all just for the moment
because time is moving on and it all
really brings us uh to the big unknown
question what could happen next how long
could the fighting rage on fork and
meaningful negotiations begin and if
there is a ceasefire of sorts how could
it work will it work
um Carl I want to start with you I think
it was Mark Twain who said history
doesn't repeat itself but it often
Rhymes what can we learn from previous
conflicts that may instruct
or inform what could happen in Ukraine
well I think there's a couple of things
that we can sort of bring up that we've
already talked about and I think the one
of the one of the crucial issues is is
the way in which we can identify certain
elements of a Playbook that as I say
authoritarian
rulers will often use both in terms of
when we talked about you know the kind
of the
establishing pretense for an invasion by
by you know loudly proclaiming about
um
one's own citizens or relate kin of
One's Own citizens being involved and
um being kind of you know suppressed or
oppressed and that's the way that
um you justify those kind of incursions
those kind of
um assaults those kind of expeditionary
warfare that's obviously a kind of
classical Playbook but it doesn't kind
of get you to the end point it doesn't
tell you how those kind of things things
end
um I think broadly speaking what that
kind of The Echoes that we will that we
will see having the most resonant impact
are going to be the ones around the the
more
the the simpler aspects of what provides
those kinds of off-ramps for people in
conflict
um we've already seen what resilience
will do
um you know how resilient the Ukrainian
people have been we've already seen how
that kind of is is is almost related
generationally to the experience of the
ukrainians I think Ukraine's own history
um also offers some powerful pointers
you know this is a country that
um another proverb you know when two
elephants fight it's the grass that
suffers Ukraine has been one of those
countries that has been fought over for
different reasons and for that
reason that I think the people of
Ukraine sort of have a a great sense of
of what Independence actually means you
know that it's been so hard fought for
um that they have a history that
includes genocide I think who's the
holodom or that includes all of the you
know this tremendous suffering
um I think the pointers from those
aspects of History are around the fact
that that people who wish to see their
freedom maintained will invariably fight
incredibly hard for us
right we have a question I think about
what's going to happen next from Philip
if you could put your hand up Philip you
had a question for yeah what was your
question because I think Michael
um
how does the panel think that the onset
of winter will change the campaign for
both sides
and what might be the possible
consequences
yeah well I I think the I mean winter as
we say changes the campaign makes it
intrinsically easier to be defensive
rather than offensive but it works both
ways it helps certain things in in an
offensive way because the ground goes
harder for armored vehicles and so on
um but in general I think we'll we'll I
mean battles never go in a straight
Tempo and it's impossible to imagine
this war carrying on at this intensity
indefinitely so I think it'll go up and
down my guess is that it will certainly
run into next year I think my guess is
it is a guess that there'll be an
unstable ceasefire in place which will
probably favor Ukraine more than we
thought it would have a couple of months
ago and that that ceasefire May last for
a few months or whatever it'll probably
break down I think you know this is the
second Russia Ukrainian war first in
2014 the first land grab Russia uh
committed this is the second war I think
probably a third war and a fourth War
because this as we say is an existential
issue uh between Ukraine and Russia and
I guess it will go for 20 or 30 odd
years
um and it'll be an on off conflict which
is why we've got to start to think about
it in the west this matters to us
terribly it matters hugely to us and to
the stability and prosperity and freedom
of Europe and so we've got to be
prepared for that and to think that
through there won't be a peace deal
sometime next year and then we can all
forget about it for a while it won't be
like that this is this is an ongoing
conflict which will which will flare up
and maybe die down and flare up and die
down for a generation
um any other questions uh we're running
out of time slightly but anybody got a
question about uh
what could happen next yes yeah
um sorry my name's Elizabeth I just came
back from Ukraine I've been out there
for seven months primarily in the
donbass just to pick up from Michael's
point just there
which is possibly more of an observation
but I'm interested to hear all of your
thoughts
we are all very lucky that we are across
the channel and we are The Far Side of
Europe
but Ukraine is actually much closer than
all of us think
um I drove out there on my own and my
little Peugeot in two days
that is how close it is
and it's another two days from there to
where I live in bogorovsk in Donetsk now
according to Future now live in Russia
but
what I think is slightly strange in the
UK
is that we do not all necessarily
realize
how fragile our existence here is
how this is right on our doorstep
and
how very quickly if these things become
more unstable
this can affect us here
much more than people worrying about
energy bills or food bills
and us paying those fuel bills and those
few bills are us fighting a war in the
only way that we currently at home
currently can
so as I say that was more of an
observation than a thought but I'm
interested to hear what you all think so
well thank you very much for that
thought and I mean Deborah how do you
see that the coming months it's such a
fundamental point that you make and I
think that's the real challenge for the
West Russia is on a war footing the head
of gchq the other day sort of talked
about how Russian Rockets were running
out I'm sure Russia's industrial base is
also on a war fitting and yes they're on
they're heavily sanctioned but we're
doing everything possible to be able to
replenish stocks what's the West doing
where is the um where is the action on
behalf of Western industry in terms of
rebuilding stockpiles of weapons of of
ammunition that have been eroded ever
since the peace dividend that was reaped
following the end of the Cold War and
it's really interesting listening to the
political narrative now over the course
of the last few weeks where your people
are the politicians the pr the previous
prime minister and the current prime
minister
for economic strength economic growth in
order to increase defense spending it's
completely the wrong way around if you
don't have security you don't have
anything else okay and I think what's
happening in Ukraine really underlies
that and we all need to wake up to it
okay Deborah thank you very much and uh
to you all thank you very much well when
I covered the uh war in the Balkans I
honestly thought I would never see war
in Europe again in my lifetime I'm sure
many people felt the same but how wrong
we were in April in harkive I spoke to a
man who lost his young wife in a missile
strike on the city this he said this
cannot be happening in the 21st century
we are a modern independent country and
differences should not be resolved by
War this is madness he said he is of
course right but the madness knows show
no sign of ending that's it for tonight
thank you to our panel our audience and
everyone at the Imperial War Museum
Institute the work they do here to
document past conflicts allows future
generations to help understand the
Sacrifice from all of us here
good night
[Music]